pakistan stands
that the conflict in afghanistan
never had a military solution
was confirmed
the ideal time to end the conflict
through negotiations
might have been
when the u.s and nato troops were at
their max maximum military strength in
afghanistan
continuation of foreign military
presence for a longer duration now
would not have yielded
any positive outcome
therefore
endorsement
by the biden
administration of the previous u.s
administration's decision of troop
withdrawal
was indeed a logical conclusion
to this conflict
it is now time for the international
community to work together
to ensure an inclusive political
settlement
for a long-term peace security and
development
of afghanistan
ladies and gentlemen
pakistan
is making
active efforts
to promote
an inclusive political
settlement in afghanistan
we
at her invitation
the
leadership
of a number of political parties and
groups in afghanistan
representing all the multi-ethnic groups
apart from the pashtuns
are present in islamabad
and have met with our foreign minister
and with our leadership
today
they have promised
to engage
continuously with the taliban
and to try to invo evolve
an inclusive afghan government
pakistan will work with them
and with the taliban representatives
to advance this objective
an objective of an inclusive political
government
which is important for durable peace and
stability in afghanistan
if we had spoken in the council we would
have also informed the council of the
efforts we are making
to facilitate the safe evacuation of
diplomats
representatives of international
organization
and others from afghanistan
pakistan's foreign secretary
today briefed the diplomatic core in
islamabad
that the embassy of pakistan in kabul
will continue to facilitate visas
for diplomats and other international
personnel
whenever needed arrangements will be
made for issuing visas to such people on
arrival
a facilitation center has been set up by
our ministry in our ministry of interior
to ensure the expeditious processing of
visas and other requirements to enable
the smooth and timely evacuation from
kabul
we will try to mount
a series of flights to
kabul airport
as soon as conditions allow
in order to continue the evacuation
which we have already started
earlier today
we have evacuated a number of
people
out from the danish
embassy
421 afghan employees of the danish
embassy which we are
evacuating from from kabul
thirdly pakistan
has called upon all afghan parties
including the taliban to ensure the
preservation of law and order in kabul
and elsewhere
our immediate priority should be aimed
at the maintenance of law and order
and safety and security of all afghan
civilians especially women and children
fundamental human rights must be upheld
all civilian property and infrastructure
must be protected
they must be complete respect for human
rights
and international humanitarian law
and we support the statement of the
secretary general in this regard
fourthly the safety and security of the
diplomatic community and premises as
as well as u.n personnel humanitarian
workers and other
international staff is paramount
there is need to urgently address the
humanitarian situation in afghanistan
unama we hope will make an evaluation of
the humanitarian needs of the afghan
people we urge the u.n secretary general
to report as soon as possible on the
humanitarian needs in afghanistan in
order to mobilize emergency help through
ocha and other international agencies
we call on all afghan parties
to ensure unhindered access
and humanitarian
aid across afghanistan as well as to
ensure the safety and security of u.n
personnel and humanitarian workers
pakistan will facilitate such operations
ladies and gentlemen apart from these
immediate actions the international
community should look ahead
to other steps designed to promote
durable peace and stability in
afghanistan
the infrastructure destroyed in this
long conflict
needs to be reconstructed including the
transport infrastructure which can
enable afghanistan to serve as a hub for
regional trade and commerce
the international community also needs
to engage
with the new authorities in afghanistan
to eliminate the threat posed by
terrorist organizations
which have used afghanistan's territory
with the sponsorship of the intelligence
agencies of some of our neighbors for
attacks and sabotage against pakistan
and other
other neighbors of
afghanistan
groups such as the daesh
the ttp the jua
the etim
imu these are all organizations which
must be contained and their activities
constrained and eliminated from the
territory of afghanistan
ladies and gentlemen uh that is what i
had to say
open to your questions
ambassador
you talk about an inclusive government
for afghanistan but don't the taliban
now want to rule on their own do you
have any indication from the taliban
that they would accept an inclusive
government
and if they don't will pakistan
recognize the taliban again as the
government of afghanistan
um
i think the taliban have said
that they will accept an inclusive
government
that they would
wish to have a government which
represents
all
groups in afghanistan and we would like
to take them at that word we are working
towards that and that's why we have
invited
the representatives of the afghan
parties or the non-pashtun afghan
parties there in islam about today we're
talking to them they are agreeable to
engage with the taliban in order to
form a
inclusive
authority and we hope that our efforts
and the efforts of other friends will be
successful
michelle nichols from reuters how
important is the role of women in a new
afghanistan government and how concerned
are you by reports of
rights abuses by the taliban against
women
thank you now i i it is obvious that the
women of afghanistan
must continue to play an important role
they have demonstrated their ability to
do so and we are hopeful
that the taliban authorities and the
new inclusive government will respect
that and will enable them to play that
role the taliban statements have said
that
they will
that they are accept
girls education women
women's
working
under an islamic system
and and as you know in islam women have
equal rights and we hope that those
rights will be respected uh in any new
uh
formation in afghanistan
i'm sorry and that women should be a
part of any new government there should
be female members of a new afghan
government well we hope there will be
female members of the afghan government
it is of course for the afghans
themselves to come forward and put
forward women candidates for women
who are willing to be part of this
inclusive government but we certainly
from our part would hope
that women will be represented and will
be able to participate in the future of
afghanistan did you say you're
evacuating pakistani nationals or afghan
nationals we are evacuating
all diplomatic personnel
all diplomatic personnel who wish to
evacuate and wish to come through
pakistan
are all representatives of international
agencies
who have requested our help in being
evacuated
and all other personnel who
feel that they are in danger we would be
willing to
look at the possibility of taking them
out
so you're helping un national staff and
international staff absolutely evacuate
absolutely
we are in touch with all the
international agencies imf world bank
etc who have have offices in
kabul
and whoever wishes to leave
from the diplomatic personnel
and from the international agencies we
will process the visas sometimes some of
the visas we will issue on arrival
so we will facilitate
their evacuation
the issue of course now is kabul airport
apparently
there has been some some incidents there
so i hope that we will be able to resume
flights uh the pakistani international
airlines will arrange the flights and we
will take out people
who we process when was the last time a
flight went out from today today
so they're at the airport this morning
we evacuated personnel from the danish
mission
so the taliban is cooperating with with
pakistan on this evacuation well the
international airport as you know is
under us control now
ambassador one more question
in terms of the way pakistan sees things
the inclusive government but after that
does democracy return to afghanistan
does pakistan believe
afghanistan should still have a
democratic system
well
you know
james we have we have a democratic
system for afghanistan the final choice
is the
it's for the people of afghanistan to
choose
whether they will have what is the
system they want they want the islamic
system
uh i think they have to
talk amongst themselves and evolve what
sort of system they want it's obvious
that we will need a new constitution
will be needed and it is for them
therefore to evolve that constitution
amongst themselves and we would not wish
to dictate anything in that regard